hey guys so today it's Easter and of
course usually we have the annual Easter
egg hunt the past couple years I have
not been home to do the Easter egg hunt
so here I am we're back here in
Pennsylvania my dad is gonna go hide
some more eggs and there's breeding oh
oh and we got outfits this year we've
got the camo going on of course it's
gonna be great
three cameras rides Camelot pick that up
for you today oh gosh oh boy
crap just cheating
Oh 15
to be fair you should never leave you
bastard
i whistle - I like I always will do now
time for Bo's egg hunch he's good get
the eggs
at the end of our egg hunts not really
sure what I filmed because I have my dad
filming some stuff on and this other
camera and didn't win Brian's sister won
she's uninvited from all future egg
hunts as is Brian let's not invite him
anymore
oh hell we can hear us break show us at
Ringo
look at this Brian nice nice pickin
maybe we will invite you back he's gonna
be our brother brother brother bakes
baby bags alright first nothing brother
maybe me better than girl I we don't
need no man we don't need no man no